[Music]
this is the Caribbean and so we're we're
accustomed to the storms and the
hurricane especially from June to
November which is hurricane season 2017
we had two major hurricanes category
five hurricane Irma Maria they came one
week apart of each other I was stuck in
a shelter with 170 other individuals and
after that experience where we couldn't
reach anybody we couldn't call to get
help I decided Well it had to be another
way and so that's why I joined um become
a ham operator I am radio with the use
of radio frequency across the airwaves
uh no wire connections at all it is a
way of communicating when all else is
down and you can actually transmit voice
and or data across the airwaves why do
we need ham radio why do we need
repeaters because in times of disasters
like for instance our hurricanes we
might lose electricity for days or weeks
or maybe months
so we do use amateur radio to
communicate between ourselves and simply
the repeaters allow us to have a station
that allows us to enhance our signal it
does this using uh what you might think
of almost as an amplifier it changes it
from 5 watts to maybe 80 Watts the idea
for the grant was to provide CPR and AED
training to amateur radio operators and
also purchase repeaters for the island
of Saint Thomas
when I should decide to strike our goal
is that l m Grant will help with
technology and information for folks who
help themselves and that can save lives
foreign
disasters and so if something should
happen medically where somebody passes
out or they need
um first aid then amateur radio
operators will be able to assist until
professional help arrives more repeaters
on the island will provide for a greater
coverage to transmit messages throughout
without the repeat of the average
transceiver could give you anywhere
between 5 to 20 miles
and with a repeater that could be
extended up to a few hundred miles
but just one repeater we have down in
the west of the island
that area is very poorly covered by even
telephone systems so having a repeater
down there will definitely be a plus for
the island
we actually link all of the repeaters on
all three islands so if you're talking
to one repeater on Saint Croix you're
broadcasting across the U.S Virgin
Islands ham radio is a is a hobby and
it's a service that brings together
technology Communications and people and
so I'm doing this as a service to the
community
[Music]